okay so the topic of this video today is
codominance genetic inheritance so let's
get started so if you watch my other
videos we've been learning about genetic
problems with this fictional family here
the Henderson family and we're here
today because Sofia's had a close call
their six-year-old daughter Sophia turns
out she was a passenger in a recent car
accident she was riding with the parents
of a friend when another driver lost
control of their vehicle and caused the
crash now she's recovering in the
hospital now and she should make a full
recovery but she lost a lot of blood in
the accident and she needed a blood
transfusion to save her life
so here's the doctor that's been working
with the Henderson family throughout
this particular story with this cartoon
family and he says you know due to her
injuries she lost some blood so we had
to give her a blood transfusion and the
mom says you know Sofia has blood type-a
how did the transfusion go do the
transfusion go well and yes in time
she'll make a full recovery
you know what let's talk about blood
type inheritance blood type follows the
codominant inheritance pattern and
that's kind of the topic of this video
today so we're gonna learn about
codominance kind of following blood type
as our example well first of all let's
look at the definition of codominance
it's when a single gene has more than
one dominant allele we haven't seen that
before with the other genetic patterns
that we've learned so far a good visual
example of this is cattle coat you know
the color of the fur of let's say cows
and pretend we have a male a male cow
that has a red coat to it and pretend we
have a female cow with a white coat well
if they were to reproduce what color
offspring would we see
well if red were dominant then you would
predict the offspring would have a red
coat to it
if white was dominant then you might
predict that the offspring would have a
white coat on it well what does
codominance look like if we're talking
codominance does the red and the white
do they blend together to make pink as
adorably cute as that would be newborn
baby cows having a pink fur color to
them no that's that's not what
codominance is in a great a visual
example codominance would look like this
this is the color pattern known as roan
notice there are patches of red at the
same time patches of white both colors
are equally expressed has red
overpowered white no has white
overpowered red no they're both equally
expressed at the same time okay now
we're gonna focus on human blood types
but I wanted to go over that cow example
first because it's more visual let's
focus now on human blood types great
example of codominance here we have a
man and a woman let's pretend mom has
blood type a what the a means is that
there are little proteins on the outer
surface of her red blood cells we call
these just the a protein let's pretend
the man has blood type B what that means
is there are little proteins on the
outside of the red blood cell and we
call these the B proteins
well if they produce a child
notice how the child would have type a B
blood is a dominant to be know is B
dominant to a know we have a child with
type a B both blood types kind of are
expressed at the same time
characteristics of blood type a from the
mom and characteristics of blood type B
from the dad so blood type a B is a
great example of codominance
so let's look at blood types in a little
more detail in humans there are three
alleles for blood type there's the a
allele which happens to be dominant
there's the B allele which happens to be
dominant and then there's the O allele
happens to be recessive so what if the
child receives an A allele from mom and
an allele from dad
this is homozygous to capital A's we
would call this homozygous and the child
would have type A blood well what if the
child receives a dominant a allele from
one parent and a recessive allele from
the other well a is dominant so this
would be blood type A but because the
child receives a dominant and a
recessive allele we would call this
heterozygous so when it comes to blood
type A notice there are two possible
genotypes there's a homozygous genotype
and a heterozygous genotype well what if
the child receives a dominant B allele
from each parent we would call this
homozygous homozygous for blood type B
what if the child receives a dominant B
allele from one parent and a recessive
allele from the other this is still
blood type B because b is dominant we
would just call this heterozygous so
when it comes to blood type B there are
two possible genotypes that would lead
to blood type B there's a homozygous
genotype and a heterozygous genotype
what if a person inherits two recessive
alleles from each parent well we would
call this homozygous recessive and like
we said earlier type A and type B are
dominant to Type O type O is recessive
and so because the O allele is recessive
this is the only way to inherit blood
type O if your genotype is two recessive
O's that's the only possible combination
that would lead to blood type O well
what if a person were to receive a
dominant a allele from one parent and a
dominant B allele from the other this is
co dominant blood type this is blood
type a B well we said earlier type a is
dominant type B is dominant there Co
dominant and so as our doctor says this
is the only way to inherit blood type a
B the
only genotype possible for blood type a
B is to receive a dominant aioli or from
one parent and a dominant B allele from
the other
so let's come back to our family here
Gillen says I actually I actually have
codominant blood
I am type A B so in the pedigree for
Dylan I can label a B as his genotype
and Maria the mom says well I actually
have type B blood the problem is there's
one two there are two possible genotypes
for type B blood well now she says and
my dad my dad was Type O
well that's very telling if her dad is
Type O then he would have passed and oh
and Leal to her so she cannot be
homozygous dominant Maria must be
heterozygous for type B blood and so I
can go ahead and label heard her circle
in the pedigree as the genotype B with
the recessive oh and the doctor says
well now let's do a Punnett square so
there's the a B for Dylan there's the B
oh for Maria when I fill in the punnett
square I can see there's a chance they
can have a child with a B blood there's
a chance they can have a child with type
A blood although that's heterozygous
type A here is the possibility that they
have a child with homozygous for type B
blood and here's the possibility they
could have a child who's Type B but
heterozygous for Type B and the doctor
says earlier you said Sophia was blood
type A so that means Dylan says that
means that I passed along my a allele to
Sophia
and Maria says I must have passed along
my recessive allele to Sofia so in the
punnett square I can see that Sophia has
blood type A but she must have the
heterozygous version of blood type a in
the punnett square there's no other way
to have type A blood in this example
and the doctor says well what about
Nikolas and Joshua Dillon says well I
can see there's a 25% chance they could
have Type A B blood one square out of
four Marina says there's a 25% chance
they could have type A blood one square
out of four and the doctor says and
there's a 50% chance they could have
type B blood according to this punnett
square two squares out of four is 50% so
here's a practice problem what I'd love
you to try to do is pause the video read
through that quick story and try to
answer these three questions I'm gonna
go over the answer in three two one
okay so the story says mike is
heterozygous for type A blood and Lisa
is heterozygous for type B blood now I
can do the punnett square and when I'm
done filling in the punnett square I can
analyze it really quick I can see
there's a possibility they have a child
with type a B blood there's a
possibility they have a child with a
blood there is a possibility they have a
child with type B blood and there's a
possibility they have a child with type
O blood so look at question a what's the
probability of having a child with type
A blood I hope you see it's one square
out of four 25% for question B what's
the probability of having a child with
codominant blood you can see that's one
square out of four as well type a B is
the codominant blood type and then
question C what's the problem
probability of having a heterozygous
child well I hope you said 75%
heterozygous means a different
combination of alleles and so three
squares out of four is heterozygous in
this example here's another practice
problem pause the video and try to solve
these three questions right here I'm
gonna go over the answers in three two
one
so first of all Jason and Maria circle
for Maria and a square for Jason Jason
and Maria they have a child by the name
of Rick I saw everything Rick implies a
boy's name so there's the square for
Rick the story says two
as type-a blood but there's two
possibilities for type-a blood but the
story also says he's homozygous for
type-a blood so he has to have two
capital A alleles Maria has type B blood
but there's two possibilities for type B
blood but the story says Maria is
heterozygous for type B blood and Rick
has Co dominant blood
well that is Type A B so now we've got
the genotypes of all three people but
now I can do question B it says complete
a punnett square for Jason to capital
A's and Maria being an O allele when I
do the punnett square for Jason and
Maria I can then analyze it and I can
see for question C what are the odds
that Rick would have type a B blood from
the punnett square you can see that the
odds were 50% there was also a 50%
chance he could have had type A blood
according to the punnett square okay
this problem is a little harder because
it combines knowledge not just of
codominance like we learned today in
this video but also knowledge of
sex-linked inheritance so if you
understand sex-linked inheritance and
codominance I'm hoping you can answer
these four questions pause the video try
to solve them I'm gonna go over the
answer in three two one
okay so first of all let's focus on the
co dominant aspect of this question I
have a wife that has Co dominant blood
so she must have the a and the B allele
and the man is heterozygous for type-a
blood so he must have the and the O
allele when I fill in the punnett
squares for blood typing that's what it
should look like now I transition over
to the hemophilia portion of this
problem which is a sex-linked disorder
the story says the wife is also a
carrier of haemophilia so there's her
genotype in the punnett square now the
man has no history of haemophilia in his
so there's his genotype as it relates to
hemophilia when I fill in the sex-linked
punnett square it should come out
looking like this right here now I can
focus on the probability questions what
is the probability it's the first one of
having a hemophiliac with type B blood
well the odds of having a hemophiliac
are one in four but the odds of having a
child with type B blood are also one in
four so does that mean the answer is
one-fourth
no what I have to do is multiply the 1/4
of the punnett square on the left by the
1/4 of the punnett square on the right
and when I do I get the final answer of
1/16 look at the next question what is a
probability of having a hemophilia
carrier with type A blood well I can see
the chances of having a hemophilia
carrier are one in four the punnett
square on the right shows me that but
then the probability of having someone a
child with type A blood the punnett
square on the left shows me the chances
of having a child with type A blood are
one-half so I take the one half of the
punnett square on the left times the one
fourth of the punnett square on the
right and my final answer is 1/8 and now
the last one what is the probability of
having a girl with type A blood I can
see the odds of having a girl are 1/2
and the odds of having a child with type
A blood are also 1/2 so I take the one
half of the two punnett squares multiply
them together and the answer is 1/4
so this picture right here is just
showing all the members of the Henderson
family that have been discussed over the
course of the the four topics that we've
learned autosomal recessive autosomal
dominant sex-linked and then also
today's topic of codominance so despite
the many struggles in the Henderson
family they are looking forward to their
future so I hope you found these videos
helpful and thank you for watching